well I haven't seen the uh the report
it's a completely independent report
it's the body that looks at uh senior
appointments so it's independent of
government I've not seen the detail yet
I mean if if that is what the report
says I do think uh kiosama has got some
serious questions to answer
well question C should we I will find
out a little bit later on today in the
meantime where are we on creating safe
legal routes for Sudanese refugees well
we have uh We've passed the common
stages of the illegal migration Bill we
did that last week because you know
there are elements within that bill for
the creation of safe and legal routes
the decision as to which and when and
how will be ones made for uh for the
home office the Home Secretary to make
the point is of course sadly Sudan is
not the only conflict around the world
at the moment so we have to look at
these things in the round and we will
always discharge our duty to be you know
a generous Nation we have used our
evacuation flights to help evacuate some
Sudanese Nationals as well as the
British Nationals and other countries
Nationals that we have supported and
decisions about safe and legal routes as
I say it's one home office they'll be
coming out in due course if they come
over on a small boat they will be
allowed to stay while they're claiming
Asylum and that is looked into
potentially being housed on boats
including on the mersey is that right
so I've I've seen the I've seen some
speculation about that I've not had the
chance to discuss that with the home
office this morning the point is we are
seeing not necessarily uh just from
Sudan but we are seeing unprecedented
levels of illegal migration it is not an
issue just for the UK when I speak to my
European colleagues these are challenges
that they are dealing with other
countries as well we have to have a
legal system which is up to date
deals with the world as it is at the
moment where we have very very large
numbers of legal migrants in many cases
facilitated by people traffickers you
know disgusting evil practice of trading
in human misery but the bill is there to
make sure our processes are fit for
purpose and Swift and fair will we keep
will you support keeping migrants on a
boat on the mersey well as I say I'm not
I'm not going to support it I'm not
going to speculate that because I
haven't seen any of the details as well
as I've said I've seen uh I've I've seen
some brief headlines uh speculating I
don't know any of the details what I'm
not going to do is comment on on uh on
speculation or things that I don't know
the details of
would be to house them in disused air
bases like in Braintree in Essex but you
don't support that well what I've said
your constituency what I've said is so
I've made my points about the specific
location but what I have always
supported I've always supported the need
to process migration claims quickly
that's what the bill was about it was
about making sure that the migration
system is not abused by people who are
seeking to manipulate it but is but is
uh but is still very much protecting the
people that need our protection and the
point is and what I've always said is
the need for large-scale accommodation
is of course no one would want
a facility like that in their
constituency
but the point that I'm saying but the
point I'm saying is that the the
legislation that we are putting through
is to reduce the need for facilities
like that okay speed up the processing
to speed up the processing okay you've
told me that yeah foreign secretary um
why do you not want them in your
backyard well I've I've said
um on a number of occasions I have
concerns about the remoteness of the
site and the uh the the road Network
around that but the bottom line is if
the decision is made that that is uh
where this site needs to be and it's not
a decision for me to make exclusively
it's but if that is the decision to make
I want to make sure it works effectively
properly and our wider migration system
is fit for purpose and these things are
not incompatible at the moment what
we're always saying what we've always
said 1500 what we've always said what
we've always said is that the nature of
migration
has changed and changed incredibly
quickly the people traffickers are
adapting their uh practices they are
advising migrants on how to manipulate
the system so we have to make sure that
with any evolving or adapting process
that we evolve and adapt our response to
it and that's what the illegal migration
bill is all about
um
we talked about sugary at the start what
about Simon case who's basically the
right-hand man for the Prime Minister he
was there with partygate when that
happened he's been there and caught up
in the middle of the BBC chairman
problems and said Anthony Selden this
morning saying he should be resigned in
his words does he have your full support
well he is the uh he is a prime
minister's appointment I've worked with
Simon I've always found him a very
thoughtful very very professional uh
ultimately it's not you know my decision
it's decision for the uh for the Prime
Minister and as long as Simon enjoys the
prime minister's support as I say in my
experience I've always found him
thoughtful professional and a very very
good public servant and so he has your
full support as I say it's not my
appointment is
it's a prime minister's appointment the
only person who Simon needs to have the
confidence of is the prime minister and
I say but from my observation he's
thoughtful incredibly professional very
very effective what about this route at
the weekend about people who don't want
to swear allegiance to the king do you
have any sympathy with them well look
it's an individual choice there's an
invitation a very generous invitation to
expand what has traditionally been quite
an exclusive
function which is just for members of
the House of Lords to swear a legion to
the new monarch actually the the King
has decided to to kind of open this up
to give everyone the opportunity to no
one is forced to no one has to No One's
Gonna Be checking if you want to do it
and I will great if you don't want to do
it fine
um I'm almost out of time
um chiefly is of course your Chief knee
I should say is your Grace and Faith
home have you been checking how many
bathrobes there are there no
um of course Liz truss apparently took
some with her when she was there so I
don't so uh
so the so the uh the rules for achieving
are are quite clear uh when you use it
you have to pay for the costs of of
doing so
um like the details of that I don't know
about my understanding is that uh quite
understandably Liz wants to make sure
that uh this is what I understand the
case I've not spoken to her directly
about this it's to make sure that the
invoice is is accurate and you know once
once that's been checked she's going to
pay it but you can see why um members of
the public who are struggling to pay
their bills at the moment will think
how on Earth can people expect us to be
paying for the food when they know very
well that they should be doing that and
shoving bathrobes in their bags before
they leave well look it's a serious
point so any of the costs are paid for
by the uh the foreign secretary when I
have used achieving on occasions that's
what I have done that's what always
happens so there's no there is no cost
to the public person it's quite
important to remember the house was a
gift to the state it's on costs are run
by the working farm that surrounds the
house and any additional cost for its
use is paid for by the individuals
there's no cost to the public person